ben i don't know mike we spent a lot of
time this week talking about all the
money that the lakers rightfully so
uh gave lebron james uh and anthony
davis
a couple of extensions 85 million for
the king
190 over five uh for anthony davis
some talk coming out of la michael holly
i don't know if you saw this uh jared
dudley
talking about he's expecting a.d to make
a uh
an mvp push this year
lebron ain't trying to not win another
one but what you think about that
uh well this is what i think about it
wasn't he in the mvp convert he should
have been
i know he wasn't it came down to giannis
and lebron
but if you look at anthony davis's
season last year that's the mvp
caliber season and and the only reason
we didn't say it is because he's playing
on the same team as lebron
but anthony davis has had if you look at
his career i know i've switched on this
i've totally switched on it mike
uh and i own it but if you look at some
of the
accomplishments throughout his career
he's had
mvp seasons before and for them to
get to that point that i talked about
where i said the lakers extend
contracts and windows if they're going
to continue
uh the mini dynasty that i think they
can have and many
meaning like two or three championships
in a four year span
something like that anthony davis will
have to be the mvp
for that to happen vinnie do you can he
win an mvp
with the best player in the world on his
team like you
do you have a vote you have a vote right
vinny don't you have a vote yup i have a
vote
so mean you tell me mike you got it you
you got to show me a world where lebron
james isn't the driving force on any
team
that he's played on and willingly sees
that space
because i remember cleveland he said you
know i'm going to be handing off a
little bit more to kyrie irving this
year i know we're going to get to kyrie
in some of his nonsense
in a minute but i don't see a world
where
lebron who has who is as
aware of his place in history aware
of his standing in theater in terms of
basketball theater
i don't see him taking a place where he
willingly
sees that even to someone like anthony
davis because i don't think anthony
davis has this dominant personality
he's going to say this is now mine and
lebron says you know what you write is
yours
but i do agree that for this to happen
there has to be some sort of
magic kareem passing of the torch
to maximize what they have better
because the guy who let them in
scoring rebound field goal percentage
three-point shooting
blocks steals and free throw shooting
last year was not lebron james
it was anthony davis so the question is
is anthony davis
already the best player on that team
oh okay oh no you're getting you know
what vinnie getting warmed up
vinnie getting warmed up for friday you
know he's just like let me try to
let me just talk to him i know what
you're doing and let me just
okay he is okay look
vinnie come out shooting vinny you you
you are not a
you are not a bench player you just
don't start you know you just don't
start for brother from another but you
you're a scorer you go
you come out scoring with these things
um
staying in that later man this clippers
drama we talked about it earlier this
week
uh the athletic unloaded on the clippers
and the special treatment the
preferential treatment and uh that kyrie
excuse me uh kawhi leonard has been
getting uh with that organization and
and michael i don't think i said this to
you michael
i had vinnie's voice in my head because
i feel like when they were collapsing
against the nuggets
no i'm serious i feel like when they
were collapsing against the nuggets you
were on the show
talking about the lack of leadership on
the floor i
i feel like you spoke to that uh and
then by the way i know if y'all saw this
paul george michael you see this paul
george today said he wants to retire a
clipper
just come on whatever that's worth yeah
but
but then read that athletic story and
all the dirty launchers
at the deadline it just but really it
just kind of feels like
you know that they don't have a fighting
chance given the chemistry issues
that they had last year and then i don't
know how they would have fixed it this
year just by switching off the coach
well you didn't just switch out the
coach montrez harold isn't there anymore
and depending on who you talk to around
the league
maybe patrick beverly can be had maybe
lou williams can be had
and my thing is kawhi leonard and paul
george receiving special treatment
like make them bad or anything like
you're going to push the limit as far as
you
can on if somebody tells you you can be
late and you ain't got to practice or
you ain't got to come to work yeah you
play when you want to play
and they say yes then that isn't
necessarily
on you at this point it's incumbent upon
coi to say okay you know what if i'm
going to be the de facto leader of this
team if
this is my organization this is my
franchise then i have to see and be
aware of what this looks like to
everybody else
and if that's the case then i have to
put some guardrails
on my own sort of special treatment now
now does he have the self-discipline to
do that
i don't i'm not saying i don't i'm not
sure but i don't know who necessarily
does if you give them all that freedom
i think their problem is just they don't
have a point guard and they didn't go
out and get a point guard and maybe they
will at the trade deadline
but to me i still look at them as being
deep enough and good enough to compete
with the lakers
the problem is the lakers get better and
the problem is you have far more queens
than answers and look paul george can
want to retire a clipper i thought he
retired in game five of the western
conference center
i don't remember seeing them oh
grim shot wait but but just i'm gonna
jump back in on one thing though
there's preferential treatment hey
listen this is all report reports
but then there's a stuff about you know
his own locker room space and how to run
people the wrong way even if it meant
you know the cheerleaders you know
weren't able to use the bathroom or
excuse me i should say female staff
weren't able to use the bathroom
late flights missing practice canceling
practice
you know uh asking in and out of games
or refusing to go into games
that's next level special special
preferential treatment special treatment
excuse me combined words
and i look at not just doc rivers
michael but like i mentioned that's
steve baumer that's organizational
you know they were just waiting thirsty
to get kawhi leonard there and paul
george ain't earned that kind of special
uh truck
i can't speak today special treatment
treatment i got you yeah but i'm with
you you know what
mike and vinnie i and just hearing all
these reports i'm glad you uh
referenced them all mike because it's
just so much of
all these all these little whispers and
innuendo and hey what do you think about
that and people just leave it out there
for you to interpret
i was offended by two things here one
that they went in on our nation's second
black president that would be glenn dock
rivers
and i didn't appreciate that at all
that's my president that's my president
leave him alone
and the other thing is look if you're if
you if you're paul george
and you're kawhi vinnie and you're a
combined
10 for 38 in a game seven
and you're a one of one guy is a
multiple
finals mvp and the other guy thinks that
he's a he's a great player
i don't want to hear anything you have
to say you were 10 for 38 in game seven
and ain't about or iq and her
accountability
you didn't get the job done and that's a
big reason
why y'all lost to uh the the denver
nuggets and blew a 3-1 lead
there's got to be some responsibility
taken by everybody
and i was a person say this i was a
person based off of kawaii 16 playoff
running that said kawhilin is the best
player in basketball
until proven otherwise until kevin
durant
that i was saying up until that kawhi
leonard was the best player in
basketball because of what he does on
both ends of the floor
he clearly was not as engaged on both
ends of the floor
especially toward the end of that series
he did not he start to look a little bit
on the heavier side like weight wise i
know a lot of that is muscle and
everything else
but i won't say the decline has happened
but that's the
first real if you think about it blemish
on kawhi because that situation with the
spurs
that felt like that was a lot of mystery
that we didn't know about you know what
i mean like there was no real blame
because there was only so much
information that we knew about
this is the first thing that's going to
stick to him a little bit and he's going
to have to i'm going to say redeem
himself because he's a two-time finals
mvp
and he's a made man but this is
something that he's going to have to
rebound from and organizationally
you got to think doc rivers
and paul george have a bit of a personal
relationship
there and there have not there's been
more than one person
around the nba that has suggested to me
hey
look they're both human you can't tell
me that these things don't play into it
at some point not necessarily when
things are going good or when things are
going bad
but when you have to give a player the
benefit of the doubt
or if a player has to give the coach the
benefit of the doubt
do they lean on that side and what i saw
in the last three games of that series
were players who did not give each other
the benefit of the doubt
and the coach who said you know what i'm
done with y'all and now i'm done with
y'all as if i'm giving up on y'all
but y'all have made this bed y'all
figure it out we've seen
coaches do that we've seen phil jackson
do that with the lakers in in portland
when they were down 17 at game seven and
he said i'll see y'all next summer you
know i'll see you next fall
and they made and they made that turn
around so it's not that doc was watching
his hands of it but at some point they
all adults out there y'all grow me
y'all y'all get yourselves into this get
yourselves out of this
and there's been a lack of
accountability i felt like from the
beginning there
because because people like me
i said they're going to get it together
when they when they have to
i gave them a certain level of grace
that they hadn't necessarily
earned they they had to hand out earned
it and now they get
not look man look mike i'm sure you've
done it just like i have
sometimes you dared a woman that was so
fine you gave her
every benefit of the doubt you gave her
every excuse that was possible
and then when you saw in the light you
was like you know what this this is my
fault
i and i am an enabler i completely
they were simping they were simping on
the front end when it was
firing bruce was uh who was it bruce
boeing when he was firing him
criticizing before he even got to kawhi
before he even got that it was simple
it was simple so um we got to get to uh
to kyrie irving man
um he spoke to him he didn't speak to
the media
he issued a statement uh he went he went
the old fashioned route
uh he addressed that did not speak to me
he addressed the media yeah one form or
another uh do we have that uh let's uh
let's show you a little bit of of what
he had to say coping 19 has impacted us
all in many ways
so i pray for the safety and health of
our communities domestically and abroad
i am truly excited for the season to
start
and i'm also praying that everyone
remains safe and healthy throughout this
journey
instead of speaking to the media today i
am issuing this statement to ensure that
my message is conveyed properly uh-oh
i am committed to show up at work every
day ready to have fun compete perform
and win championships
alongside my teammates and colleagues in
the nets organization my goal this
season
is to let my work on and off the court
speak for itself
life hit differently this year and it
requires us it requires me
to move differently so this is the
beginning
of that change okay
um all right i i guess i get it
mike vinnie look mike thinks this is
doomed to to
for disaster anyway you are not feeling
this brooklyn experiment to begin with
so
mike start it off what's your how you
probably
okay now i reserve the right once what i
said i reserve the right to be stupid i
said that before
i deserve the right to change my mind as
the facts changed so in your opinion
yeah
but my first reading of the reading like
literal reading of this fellows is that
i understand this is actually growth
from kyrie irving because he has now
what he didn't put in the statement
i'm just going to just read something
into it he has a knack
for saying too much you like some people
you give them like the notes saying
you're going from the media you're going
to say this this and this here are three
points you go ahead and do it
and they go in there and they give you
seven things they tell they say too much
like oh man why'd you do that we talked
about this beforehand
that's what he usually does in this case
he's not letting any of that other stuff
you're not gonna twist me up
i'm gonna say this is what i wanna say
this is all i wanna say and
i'm going to focus on the season i i
think it's actually good because
he's so sensitive and and durant they're
so sensitive
this is the way to do it this is i i
really don't think about
you talk about reading into things so
can you read between the lines
i'm just reading vinnie's face and body
language and i'm amused benny ain't even
saying a word yet
i'm picking up some vibes from vinnie go
ahead ben
then he feels some kind of way about it
okay if you are a grown man and you
cannot control the statements that you
say in front of the big
bad media across a zoom teleconference
i don't think kyrie irving is a bad guy
i think kyrie irving fancies himself to
be a little bit smarter than what he
is and fancies the media to be a little
too simplistic
he puts us in the box when he claims
that we put him in a box i find that
rather
amusing so whether kyrie irving doesn't
talk to the media for the rest of the
year
and this is the beginning of that change
and you guys can't twist my words
it wasn't the media that said we don't
need a coach jack i
can be the coach one day i can be the
coach one day like that wasn't the media
that said that
that was on a podcast your words not the
quotes not anything
and for me it's about guys having to
take responsibility like you are a grown
man you were doing great work he's done
great work
as far as what he was doing in terms of
social justice with what he was doing
with the wnba
and we can put all those things together
and say that
kyrie irving is a quality human being
but a lot of times he sticks his foot in
his mouth it's not that he says too much
sometimes he just says dumb stuff that
is worthy of scrutiny
and i don't think we have to necessarily
give him an excuse for saying
dumb stuff sometimes you think you are a
little
too smart and when people call you out
on it then all of a sudden well y'all
know i didn't mean it like that
y'all just twisted my words you ever had
a friend that was a little too smart
and you'd be like you're a c student be
a c student
like that i'm not saying kyrie is a c
student he is a brilliant basketball
player
he has a big heart he thinks completely
different ways but nobody told him
to say the flat nobody told
him to say that you know paul is like
the white ball
knocking the black ball off of the face
of the earth you know what i'm saying
like kyrie puts his own doors
that says pool and blames the door that
ain't awful
man since you're dropping bars on the
way out uh we were texted earlier we got
to celebrate
uh uh recognize jay-z's birthday uh
is today uh you know
i've been told that you can't have a
credible top five
without jay-z sorry he's not in my
personal top five
but there's no denying what the man
has done and continues to do uh
throughout the industry and the culture
at large so you want to uh give jay-z
some flowers on your way out benny
goodwill
can y'all get me some flowers it's my
birthday stay tuned y'all let me give
them flowers to another grown man when
today when it's my boring day
today oh man bro you wack for that
dog you whacked for that no wait wait
first of all
okay happy birthday vinnie goodwill i
can't
michael thank you mike i haven't been
burying that lead
like i ain't talking to you today say
dawg like for her
now you're making me feel better last
week i got enough stuff to
what when we talked last week when we
talked last week you you asked me and i
told you yeah my brother
michael will you tell this dude i can't
remember what people tell me this
morning
that's true that's true
bro i got enough stuff going on in my
head you got to keep texting me
okay i'm thinking about talking about
reasonable doubt
i thought we might talk about the
blueprint black album in my lifetime
and and i asked you on tech i said say
bro
what else you want to talk about today
he's like it's jay-z's bro
and i'll be like yeah what y'all want to
talk about while i say yeah let's talk
about my birthday
on your show like hot like come on i i
ain't that much
gary change into rap icon mogul
vinnie good happy birthday cousin vinnie
but if you want my my top three jay-z
rap albums is reasonable dialogue
blueprint black album the first two of
classes the third is a little bit
you know it's got too many too many
thuds
there you go okay but no but i mean you
know
what are you doing i mean we're in a
pandemic what are you doing for your
birthday man like happy birthday
first of all thank you for blessing the
show giving us the gift of on your
birthdays
all right that's your time on your
birthday some people i know
are spending their don't want to come on
show i'm not gonna say no no come on
don't wanna come on our show on their
birthday because they're busy i ain't
gonna put his business in the street i
don't want to be i'm just gonna
don't do that but that's amazing but
point b i know what you're talking about
that's an amazing story
the fact that you're here speaks volumes
of this relationship
so what are you what you doing today man
what's going on
what you got planned you said it earlier
we're in the middle of a pandemic
i feel like 2020 has been one long-ass
40-degree day
[Laughter]
i'm chilling i might have i might have a
nice a nice beverage either nice
red wine or a nice cognac you know have
a nice dinner
and and that that's kind of that's kind
of it i'm on the clock the nba schedule
just got released
kyrie irving just said something silly
paul george just went paul george on
everybody
like you know i just had to push the
vacation back a little bit i'll you know
i'm gonna go to y'all for
for recommendations because i'm sure
mike them been everywhere from santro
pay to bora bora
so you know
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you